au rayon boucherie ce matin ces deux
personnes ne sont pas venus pour acheter
plutôt pour inspecter l'objectif c'est
de contrôler que le consommateur est
correctement informés sur l'étiquetage
de l'origine des viandes mise en vente
dans cette grande surface contrôle
classique de routine très méthodique
nous avons le pays naissance la france
le pays d'élevage la france
le lieu d'abattage la france le
directeur de la grande surface a été
prévenue peu de temps avant l'opération
il n'est pas trop inquiet
toutes les équipes sont déjà habitués à
être contrôlée en permanence puisqu'on a
des audits à par des laboratoires
indépendants tous les mois ou tous les
deux mois
je vais vous dire qu'on est scruté sur
la trace at c à la lettre donc là il est
vrai qu'en ces les services de l'état à
la pression a peut-être un peu plus
importante est bon mais peut-être jamais
à l'abri d'une à dire d'une connerie
entre guillemets mais d'une manière
générale bon voilà on sait ce qu'on veut
heureusement c'est ce qui fait la
réputation d'autres magasins en pleine
crise agricole l'opération et
volontairement médiatisée pour montrer
que l'état est vigilant l'idée c'est de
montrer aux médias comment montréal
inhérents concrètement un contrôle
l'objectif de cette de cette initiative
c'est plutôt vous montrer la
méthodologie d'un contrôle de l'origine
de l'alliance donc c'est de la
communication et la logique
essentiellement pédagogique à chacun de
se faire une opinion en attendant pas
d'irrégularités constatées ce matin dans
cette grande surface